nos dicen mi libro tiene 58 páginas ya
leí 13 páginas planeo leer 5 páginas
cada día hasta que terminé el libro cuál
ecuación puedo usar para calcular
cuántos días de me llevará a terminar de
leer el libro pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver lo primero tratemos de
encontrar cuál es la información
importante que nos proporcionan nos dan
el número de páginas que tiene el libro
nos dicen cuánto hemos leído ya ya
leímos 13 páginas y también nos dicen
cuánto planeamos leer planeo leer 5
páginas cada día hasta terminar el libro
y queremos encontrar una ecuación que
nos diga cuántos días y d es la forma en
que representamos el número de días
necesitaremos para terminar de leer el
libro bueno si sabemos el número de
páginas que tenemos que leer y si lo
dividimos entre las cinco páginas que
queremos leer cada día esto nos dará el
número de días cuántas páginas nos
restan por leer del libro bueno el libro
tiene 58 páginas de las cuales ya leímos
13 por lo que restamos 13
y esta expresión nos dice cuántas
páginas nos quedan por leer vamos a
escribirlo cuántas páginas
quedan y si queremos saber cuántos días
se necesitan para leer las páginas que
quedan debemos dividirlo entre el número
de páginas que leemos cada día y aquí
vemos que leeremos cinco páginas cada
día si dividimos esto entre cinco toda
esta expresión nos dice cuántos días
quedan por lo que esto es igual a de por
qué d es el número de días que se
necesitan para terminar de leer el libro
al ver las opciones nos damos cuenta de
que la opción se tiene exactamente lo
que escribimos acá la opción a dice 58
13 pero esta sería una situación en la
que hay 13 páginas más de las 58 páginas
que tiene el libro lo que no tiene
sentido y esto ocurre tanto en la opción
a como en la opción b en la opción b
tampoco tiene sentido el multiplicar por
5 ya que no nos llevará 5 veces más que
el número de páginas para poder terminar
de leer el libro vamos a dividir entre 5
porque leeremos 5 páginas cada día y
terminamos